hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm so they're going to
be starting our coverage of the london
chess classic if you're not too familiar
this is the third leg of the race in the
Grand chess tour now this is an
inaugural tournament so it started this
year there's three legs we have the
Norway chess tournament we have the sink
filled cup and lastly we have the London
chess classic so this is the third and
final one of the year and what they do
is they take nine thats hot players in
the world they're going to be the same
in each of the tournament's they'll add
on one additional player so there's even
players throughout so each of these
tournaments will have 10 players and
then based on how you do in that
tournament you'll get point now going
into the London chess classic that the
top five players just you kind of how
they have ranked based on Norway and the
sink filled cup is toe pallavas number
one Nakamura and number two aronia
number three magnus carlsen in the world
champion number four and a niche giri in
fifth place and then you have six
through nine so with that said a lunge
chess classic is a pretty fun tournament
and there's a million dollars in the
grand chest or so a really fun way to
get the top players to be playing
consistently against each other so
that's kind of an intro into the London
chess classic in round one today this is
a nine day event we're going to be
looking at the leader topol off and he's
going to be playing the white pieces
Bulgarian chess grandmaster he's going
to be playing a nice Giri 21 year-old
Dutchman really phenomenal player he's
currently in fifth in the overall
standings uh for the entire grandchester
so a really good way to kind of kick
start off the london chess classic with
two of the powerhouses going into this
last leg of the race so we'll go ahead
and get started with pawn to d4 Knight
to f6 upon c4 pawn to g6 pawn here to g3
so if someone looks like a Grunfeld
defense with this pawn here to g6 Knight
to f6 but we kind of see the fee in
Quetta version of pawn here to g3 and
then pawn to c6 a little bit of a
variation instead of the just normal
pawn here to d5 and the Grunfeld but we
see pawn here to c 6 [ __ ] betta g2 that
think I to endow pawn here to a d5 now
why it's going to play Queen to a5 it's
a little questionable as far as
if White's going for maybe a cattle an
opening or if he's just really playing
against the Grunfeld offense but we see
night to a d7 from a nice Giri this is
the move that Boris Gelfand has played
himself and so a lot more grandmasters
are starting to play this so you're
seeing this more often we're back in the
day you didn't see this often at all toe
blob decides to go ahead and take with
this pawn here on d5 other moves instead
taken with a pond you can always play
Queen back here to a b3 see to those are
popular moves as well but after pawn
takes a now we see the night coming over
here to be 6 and then the Queen's going
to retreat back here to d1 and then the
pawn takes here on d5 from here we see
the C file open so both sides are going
to continue to develop their pieces
night here to see three nights e6 and
then pawn here to e3 and there's a few
ways that why can kind of play this he
decides to go ahead and solidify his
pawn chain but it does block off his
dark squared Bishop sotoba life is going
to have to keep that in mind the rest of
the game as far as how he wants to get
this Bishop here on c1 involved into the
game we see Bishop here to g7 fianchetto
getting ready to castle on the kingside
night here to e2 wants to make sure its
lights for a bishop is still involved
not blocked off with the night here on
f3 which is the normal move for the
night always to come here to f3 but then
castle on the kingside castle over here
and then work over here to e8 we have
seen previous matches even earlier in
this year of black playing pawn here to
e6 just solidifying the pond change just
like white did but in this year he
doesn't want to block off his life's
great Bishop he has bigger plans for his
lights for a bishop he wants to later
get his Bishop involved to g4 really
devastating to move to pin down this
night here on e2 I wanted to bring it
potentially to f5 control the center of
the board he doesn't want to block it
off because he realizes that you know
it's just going to be kind of tedious he
wants instead to kind of push forward
with pawn to e5 but before he does that
he first needs to go and bring his fruit
over here to e8 giving some protection
right here so pond here to be three this
just kind of consolidates a you know a
knight coming here to a for this c4
square as well also opens up the door
for the dark squared Bishop knowing that
it's kind of blocked off with the pawn
chain here on III d 4 + f2 you can't
really go anywhere
if doesn't want to block off as Queen
for moving so opening up the door with
pawn here to be three is pretty nice all
the way around and now pawn to e5 as we
kind of talked about after the pawn
takes other night recaptures here on e5
I personally wouldn't mind the bishop
here on e5 it does threaten pins down
this night to this rook back here on a
one I think that's fine also just kind
of keeping the finca de bishop back here
is kind of a safe move your opponent is
always going to have to be thinking
about the rest of the game because it
just controls so much of the board so
night taking on the sin of the board and
then we see pawn to h3 now White has a
ton of different options if you look at
this you may look and say okay a black
has an isolated pawn here on d5 so white
wants to put a lot of pressure on that
square he already has one night's a one
Bishop and a queen and if you look at
blacks to fence he has one queen and one
night here on b6 unfortunately can't
just take right away so if we first look
at the bishop ticking here on d5 then
the night takes and then office on the
Queen sakes but then the bishop coming
down here to h4 is pretty devastating as
far as what white really wants to do on
board it could just go ahead and take
this Queen but then after the rook it's
going to be very difficult as soon as
this night comes down here to f3 check
all of a sudden that's going to just
open up the door for this night to be
attacked or this rook back here on a one
if this night moves let me kind of look
at it here after the bishop takes and
the night comes back here then the
night's going to come here to f3 check
and then just opens up the door for the
bishop to come down here to a one and
then you know the king could come here
we could just take extra material and
then it doesn't really matter the bishop
could just come down here and take and
then I could come off the board from the
king but you kind of get the point so
you can you can imagine topol off
besides not to go ahead and do that he
didn't really quite like that instead
decided to go for the h3 there but he
could have also even tried a night to d5
but this is probably even worse you see
the night take care on d5 Queen takes we
could see that the Queen captured bishop
and then something similar but the
bishop coming down here too
three doesn't really have to move his
rook but if you wanted to you know
Bishop here first we could see the
bishop take down here on f1 all in all
this is going to be not quite as good
for white so if we come back that's just
some of the variations there's a lot of
other moves that could have occurred on
the board but that's some of the ones
that you could have seen so instead we
see upon 2 h 3 and this stops the bishop
coming down here to g4 which is very
troublesome move for top love to a plot
to have to deal with so instead and this
cheery says okay I'll go ahead and go
with the second best square and that's
the bishop here to f5 just controlling
the center of the board and then we see
night up here to a d4 two blobs main
goal right now is still to threaten this
pawn here on d5 it's an isolated pawn an
HD really has to put a lot of resources
to go ahead and try to defend that so
putting more and more pressure on that
is definitely going to be White's kind
of objective right now on the other side
Black's doing pretty good he has both of
his bishops and the sort of the board
they're very active compared to his
opponent where the dark square Bishop is
not really doing anything it's going to
be a little bit easier for him to go I
get his rooks involved into the game
recover here to see eight controlling
the C file white can't really get is a
rook a one rook really involved into the
game so both sides kind of clear as far
as what they're going to be trying to do
Bishop down here to d3 attacking the
rook their words can come over here to
e1 now the bishop comes back here to a 6
and the Queen's forced to come here to
d2 why is it forced to come here to d2
because this next move night here to d3
attacking the rook the rook really needs
an outlet without this Queen moving
can't really come here to d1 so Queen
here d 1 and then all of a sudden Bishop
to addie for this year who says I'm
going to go ahead and give you a double
bishop pair i think i can continue to
put pressure on board so i'm going to go
ahead and give up this bishop here on a
d4 and it also does give an HT re a
target here so white also has an
isolated pawn on the d file this also
opens up the door for another open file
on the e-file so if an HD we wanted to
he could come over to see aids have to
open files that he continuously
attacking with
both of his rooks now these she was
going to get his queen involved so Queen
here to f6 and then upon up here to a
for now this is a pretty sharp move
taupe lava is known for playing these
sharp removes getting in these crazy
complications it's definitely fun for
spectators it's really taxing on your
brain which was kind of surprised almost
to see it in Game one usually see some
games very passive in Game one everyone
kind of going for the drawl just go on
to later rounds and just kind of see
where you are and see if you need to
start making some moves but you don't
want to make any crazy waves going on
you could easily just play something a
little bit more basic Bishop here to f1
start to put more pressure pinning down
this night here to this Bishop this
night it really can't really too too
much and start to maybe add more
pressure on here you have your queen
attacking this this is completely fine i
think but pawn to a4 very aggressive
play now the Queen comes down takes this
isolated pawn that was kind of what an
itch to you was was kind of looking to
do so black is currently up upon but
it's going to be very easy for tok lot
to kind of get that back but now decides
have played pawn here to a5 now if you
kind of look at and say you know why
don't we just see the bishop to f1 it
just starts to kind of overload this
piece here on the three black actually
has a pretty nice defense to this and
you can see both players kind of
studying the board just to kind of see
how all the permutations would kind of
play out but after night here to d7 if
you do see the bishop take here on d3 we
see the bishop come down after the Queen
takes there's a nice in between move
that black has and it's rook here to e1
and this is kind of the reason the tope
alabi sided not to go ahead and play
this period of f1 because this work that
you want is just kind of puts the whole
plan to a to a halt right here the root
can't take here because then his Queens
going to fall so he kind of has to play
his King here to g2 and then we see the
rook take the Queen take and then the
Queen take here on c3 white just doesn't
really have any compensation for what he
was trying to do so after all this we
don't see that on the board and said we
see
on to a five forcing the night back to a
d7 right away now Rick up here to a 4 so
if we look at topol off his game plan it
was to attack the isolated pawn it
that's plan a his plan B looks to be so
go ahead and get his rook involved swing
it over to the King side and start to
have an aggressive attack on his
opponent's king side of the board so
that's plan B so Queen back here to e5
the Queen was being attacked so
definitely needs to move and then night
taking up here on a d7 and now the night
it's going to come back here to see one
now a lot of the grandmasters that we're
doing commentary on this game we're a
little disappointed that in HD where you
kind of jumped the gun and play night to
see one instead really wanted to see
night to see five getting another piece
involvement of the game controlling the
stern of the board and still adding
pressure of this d 3 squared which is as
you can tell kind of blocking off a lot
of the the key pieces for white so
really would have been nice to see a
nice to replay this but kind of opted
for the easier move but I don't feel
like it's as good and that is the night
taking here on a c1 the rook takes here
on c1 and then the night over here to f6
yeah it's a little better position than
it was here on d 7 but really it's just
not nearly as good if it was kind of
controlling this here at the board so
tupelov plays Knight to c7 he's really
starting to you know kind of put a
stranglehold on this match unfortunately
he's running out of time he only has
about 15 minutes left on the game so
it's a somewhat complicated position as
far as how you take he's probably up a
little bit just based on you know where
he's at right now he's attacking both of
these nights or these rooks right here
so that's going to be good probably a
little bit better position and can swing
his rook over and start to get that
involved but it's not very easy and he
she was going to make it very difficult
for him to do that so time is definitely
not on his side an HD replays rook to da
just centralizing as rooks it's
completely open in the cert of the board
so anytime you Riggs control long files
that's always going to be good and
they're connected as well Queen here to
f4 pawn down here to aji
five just starting the Queen Queen over
here to be four top lock doesn't yet
want to go and give up his advantage he
recognizes that he probably is winning
on board right now and so he doesn't
want to just exchanged his Queens off
the board right yet Queen down here to
be too starting to add pressure rook
down here to e2 you always want two
rooks on your opponent second rank or
seventh rank depending on which color
you are Queen up here to see five we see
pawn here to h6 just ill-defined this
pawn chain this palm was being attacked
by the Queen right here so just nice
little safe move net over here taking on
a six pond recapturing definitely better
for whites right here is the double
ponds on either the a file or the H file
or just really bad especially if there's
no connecting ponds at all or anything
to kind of help out and potentially
maybe get that non a double pair so
right now white definitely has the
better position on board rook over here
to be one attacking the Queen quid over
here to D to a bishop here to f3 and
then knight to e for now top live on
board we are at the 32nd move he only
has two minutes left in the game which
is unfortunate because it's very
difficult you're now playing almost
bullet chess where your opponent just
has so much time to think and you just
have to go rapid fire he plays Queen
here to 87 and this is a huge mistake
you should have played Bishop here to e4
things would have been completely okay
but he played Queen over here to a seven
he just probably didn't have time to
really look at the move Knight to f2 but
this is very devastating doesn't want to
come and take it with his queen it would
just fall right away so instead decides
to go ahead and take the rook but the
night up here to h3 check the Kings
going to move Queen up here to d5
getting ready to come down here to h1
check that's a very devastating move
Bishop up here to h5 that's kind of
losing this really matter though where H
goes a nice jewelry has enough time on
boards really calculate the best move
probably from here white needs to go
with King to e1 that's really the only
way to kind of get out of this mess
Bishop here to h5 really just opens up
the door for black to kind of do
whatever he wants to so Queen down here
to h1 king up here to e2 queen here to
g2 all of a sudden the ruse
over here just controlling these DNE
files then the night's going to come on
board and then all of a sudden we've
seen that appear to e4 discovered attack
with the Queen check and from here toe
claw has decided to resign so with the
white pieces coming into the last leg of
the grand chest or being in first place
and losing the first game it's
definitely not what he wanted in each
Giri though coming out the blocks with
the black pieces playing arguably the
best player at the tournament so far and
getting a win so congratulations to him
played exceptionally well in a very very
difficult game so many sharp line so
many things to think about so many
different traps that both players could
really fall into and really both the
dictionary well but just ran out of time
at the end hopefully y'all enjoy the
video had some requests to maybe go a
little bit more in depth so try to do
that in this video I will also try to do
that with the rest of the London chess
classic try to go a little bit more in
depth into some of the moves to
variation some of the things that these
grandmasters are thinking about and then
add more commentary around what other
grandmasters are saying about the game
i'm also watching the games to kind of
get a feel for how they're really going
so hopefully you find this both
informative and entertaining at the same
time really looking forward to this last
big chess tournament of the year so make
sure that you check out all the videos
we're going to be doing videos from all
the rounds i'll have a lot more material
on the chess website calm if you haven't
been checking that out as well so
everyone thanks for watching i'll see
you guys in round two